j'accueille olivier de kersauson
olivier lecat moment
bonsoir olivier panis est rempli je
connais laurent baffie ça fait une paye
que je vous attend sur ce plateau je
suis ravi que ce soit ce soir merci
d'être là mais le cacher votre émotion
mais aussi fait très plaisir sinon je
serais pas là je vais vous savez alors
dites moi ça vous énerve quand les gens
disent de kersauson les de dire
kersauson par exemple j'ai vu deux
kersauson hier soir la télé chez
ardisson
c'est aux énerve ça en général ils me le
disent pas moi que je vois pas pourquoi
ça m'énerve
et quand on vous appelle l'amiral ça
vous énerve non oui oui en général je
n'aime pas tellement qu'on parle alors
profitez-en pendant un certain temps ce
gène chez moi j'ai horreur qu'on parle
je ne crois pas de ma vie avoir adressé
la parole en premier à quelqu'un un but
un peu timide réservé réservé bien élevé
vous porter un slip un caleçon ou vous
êtes toujours nue sous vos jeans ça
dépend
venez prendre la température trop vieux
pour le sud je mets un slip pourrait en
acrylique et dans les pays chauds sinus
où mon jean
non
alors il ya au moins deux kersauson le
kersauson des villes elles kersauson de
mer on va essayer d'en parler ce soir le
kersauson devils et celui des copains la
radio de la télé de la nuit moite a pu
chuter
et puis kersauson de mer celui
d'aujourd'hui le grand navigateur qui a
déserté un petit peu depuis quelques
temps le paysage audiovisuel pour les
horizons du globe
aujourd'hui en effet vous consacrez quoi
trente heures par jour au projet phare
de votre carrière
alors c'est la mise au point du plus
grand trimaran à voile du monde
la course commence à mende et la
construction du bateau de la mise en
chantier d le choix des matériaux de
chaussons les décisions sont
irréversibles donc c'est vrai ça fait
deux ans de travail acharné passionnant
formidable oui ce qu'il faut dire dans
le jeu que dans quoi dans un mois c'est
le départ du trophée jules verne
il faut pas confondre trophée et course
un trophée c'est un record on part quand
on veut alors qu'une course il faut pas
que les autres alors le trophée jules
verne ça passe par où ma par les trois
caps est quoi l 3 4 capes cape town
fallu que l'afrique du sud 1 le caf
lewin au sud de l'australie et le cap
horn le bateau rendent en dans le grand
sud dans les quarantièmes rugissants les
50e et reste toujours cette zone là à
votre principal concurrent c'est bruno
peyron sur orange vous vous détenez le
record depuis 1997 71 jours 14 heures 22
minutes et 8 secondes six paires précis
et le bateau s'appelle geronimo alors
c'est du pur parce que vos sponsors
cap gemini ernst & young schneider
electric ils ne sont pas obligés à
appeler le bateau non au contraire il
voulait il voulait un
generix et là c'était la première fois
que ça m'arrive est ce que alors géré au
niveau c'est un chef indien de la tribu
apache déchiré kahoul a un qui a été
traqué comme ben laden par les
américains sauf que lui il a retrouvé
des cellules de la différence mais s'est
jamais rendu si jamais rendus faisant
gironimo il ya une histoire de dom qui
ne cède pas et qui est assez qui est qui
est bien et puis c'est d'une culture
indienne de d'avancé dans le silence
pour être angles et de connaître son t1
de connaître son monde de respecter son
environnement pour le sens baba cool les
écologistes de merde aujourd'hui mais
dans la réalité donc avait de la
connaissance pas un discours fait mais
un discours de connaissances connaître
le monde alors un véritable sauer je
trouve que le personnage mais j'aime
bien et puis c'est un nom c'est un nom
qui fait rêver quand des petits et
assure que quand on commence à être un
peu grand fier mon cas bien sûr ton
métier les pièges dans les bois quand
j'étais petit vous preniez pour geronimo
ouais ouais tout le temps tout le temps
mais toujours été dans ma tête
un indien et que sa fronde et ou alors
le bateau il fait 34 mètres de long 22
mètres de large le mafé 43 mètres de
hauteur ipes 20 tonnes 53 vaille 4,5
millions d'euros enfin c'est une
opération qui va peser 10 millions
d'euros ces normes nous font confiance
les mecs la graine regardez pas comme
s'il venait de chez sur la moquette jeu
c'est un domaine pendant tous
c'est un domaine dans lequel anthony a
confié bon gars merci ferme et dix
millions d'euros c'est beaucoup de pays
c'est le prix c'est le prix d'un mauvais
film moyen qui fera trois entrées non et
c'est au final
c'est le fruit d'une campagne de pub où
vous trouvez coincé entre canard wc
autre chose
c'est tout à fait des bons arguments je
comprends comment les mails ou les
baratiner non messieurs martin pas
justement moi je leur explique la
réalité et en génial comme on parle à
des gens intelligents ils la comprennent
leimer ses yeux alors ce bateau a été
baptisé le 29 septembre par l'aumônier
de la marine nationale
la marraine c'est marie tabarly kavi
sept ans et qu'elle a filles d'eric
tabarly avec qui vous avez navigué
pendant huit ans 1